[Музика]
привіт, мене звати Наталія Суперба, і
настав час для нашого уроку англійської мови, тому
я сподіваюся, що ви всі щасливі та
здорові, тому що ми багато займалися
спортом протягом цих трьох тижнів, тому
почали  три тижні тому
і сьогодні ми закінчуємо нашу тему, зараз давайте
подивимося, що ми навчилися зараз, подивіться на
цей слайд, і я сподіваюся, що ви
вже знаєте назву цього виду спорту, ви
знаєте, які наші командні види спорту, як футбол
або екстремальний вид спорту, як паркур і
стрибки з парашутом  зимові види спорту, як-от катання на ковзанах
літні види спорту, як-от теніс, індивідуальні
види спорту, як-от йога, ви знаєте, як використовувати
їх під час гри,
ви також можете сказати мені свою думку про
те, чому вам подобається чи не подобається,
наприклад, теніс чи бокс, тому що
це небезпечно і виглядає  знову в цих
портах і скажіть мені, що ви думаєте, який
вид спорту розслабляє від
цього добре, що ви думаєте, я думаю, що
йога розслабляє те, що захоплююче
захоплююче, який вид спорту захоплює, що
ви думаєте, я думаю, я вірю  Напередодні того, що
Паркер дуже захоплюючий так, але скажіть мені, будь ласка,
зараз, що є небезпечним, що є
найнебезпечнішим з
усіх цих портів, що ви думаєте,
що є найнебезпечнішим.
що таке нудний
спорт як ти думаєш, що для тебе
нудно
добре, можливо, плавання чи йога для тебе
нудно, але це нормально, тому це може бути так
далі я хотів би дати тобі диктант слів,
тож подивіться на ці слова, спробуйте
запам'ятати правопис  як записати,
а потім я дам вам слово, а
ви запишіть, вам для цього потрібен
аркуш паперу або ручка, візьміть, будь ласка, і
подивіться на список
Паркер гімнастична фехтування йога
катання на ковзанах футбол бокс і плавання
так що партнер номер один  номер два
гімнастична гімнастика
номер три фехтування фехтування номер чотири
йога йога п'ять катання на ковзанах катання на
ковзанах наступний футбол футбол
бокс бокс і плавання останнє
плавання, тому перевірте це ще раз і n  о, я
даю вам правильних батьків, щоб ви
виправляли помилки
так добре зроблено гарна робота Сподіваюся, ви
пам'ятаєте, як записати це слово або його
написання наступний слайд
я хотів би нагадати вам про незвичайний
вид спорту, який ми проходимо через нього  дуже
цікавий і дуже незвичайний, наприклад
шах, це суміш між шахами,
грою в шахи та боксом, бігами на ліжках
це дуже незвичайний вид спорту в Австралії собака
серфінг собака серфінг ви можете посадити свого улюбленця
на прибій і займатися серфінгом з ним екстремальне
прасування ви можете прасувати свій одяг
можливі дуже екстремальні ситуації – це
поєднання між стрибками з
музикою на пляжному велоспорту на м’ячі
та їздою на велосипеді разом Страусині перегони ви
використовуєте птахів для змагань підводний хокей він
існує так
підводний хокей ви граєте в хокей з
аквалангом спеціальне обладнання для дихання
під водою боротьба  ви знаєте
армрестлінг, але є інструментальна
боротьба також дивний і незвичайний
вид спорту і квідич квідич
дивна гра, яка  взято з книги про Гаррі
Поттера добре,
наступне завдання буде завершити діалог
із цими чотирма варіантами. Я даю вам на це
три хвилини, але дозвольте мені
спочатку прочитати це для вас, це діалог
між двома друзями Крісом та Джо, привіт,
Джон, я збираюся  Джим звинувачує Джон відповідає
о, привіт, Кріс,
ні, дякую, я не бачу сенсу Кріс
займатися
спортом важливо ммм, Джон,
я розумію, що ти маєш на увазі, але це так
нудно, Кріс, я зовсім не погоджуюся, це
весело, це змушує тебе почувати себе добре
бла-бла-бла  Джо, добре, тоді я
прийду, і Кріс відповість добре для
дисперсії, ви повинні спочатку помістити їх у
потрібне місце, ми добре орендуємо для вас, по-
друге, це підтримує вас у формі та здоров'я, чи
хочете ви прийти, і чому б вам не
спробувати  тому знайдіть правильне і правильне місце
для цих чотирьох фраз добре, я даю вам
три хвилини на це
[Музика]
[Музика
] час закінчився, давайте перевіримо ваше завдання,
виправте помилки, якщо у вас є
hyejeong Я йду до Джима, ти хочеш прийти,
привіт, Кріс, ні, дякую я  не бачу сенсу в
Греції фізичні вправи важливі і тримають
вас у формі та здоров'я
, хіба я не розумію, що ви маєте на увазі, але це
настільки нудно, Кріс, я зовсім не погоджуюся,
це весело, це змушує вас почувати себе добре, чому
б вам не спробувати  це, Джон, добре, тоді я
прийду, Кріс, добре для тебе, добре, і
наступне завдання — виправити помилки, ці
речення мають помилки, тому ви повинні
їх виправити, тому я даю вам на це
завдання також три хвилини
[Музика]
[Музика  ]
так що час закінчився добре, перевірте своє завдання
з правильними варіантами. Перший -
давайте після школи поплавати ми
виграли трофей - це наш
номер три футболіст не повинен
торкатися м'яча,
ми можемо'  t грати в теніс у воді
ми не можемо грати в теніс у воді я не
почуваюся сьогодні я залишаюся вдома відчуваю себе добре
не відчуваю себе добре, тому що це не
прикметники, його прислівник наступний я думаю, що
бокс небезпечніше, ніж теніс,
добре, я б хотів  спробувати не намагатися, але
спробувати віндсерфінг одного дня я люблю бути на
вулиці у воді та  востаннє, коли я
був дитиною, я міг лазити по деревах, але
зараз я,
на жаль, не можу, тому я б хотів,
щоб ви ще раз переглянули цей слайд і скажіть мені,
які види спорту з цих
популярні в Україні, що ви думаєте,
який з них  популярний в Україні добре
подумайте про це я думаю, що звичайно
футбол є найпопулярнішим видом спорту
в світі, а в Україні також бокс
гімнасти
це плавання і теніс я вважаю так,
звичайно, футбол є найпопулярнішим
видом спорту в Україні ви знаєте два
найуспішніших  клуби команди динамічні відпустки
і донецький Шахтар ти їх знаєш
звісно може ти знаєш хто
найвідоміший спортсмен у спорті звичайно
ти знаєш колишнього головного тренера київського динамо
Валерія лобановського тепер головного
тренера київського динамо андрія шевченка
ти його теж знаєш  Олександр Ціолковський,
який це той, хто знає так, він колишній
воротар колишній у минулому тепер у своїй
Бойці є воротар мотиву Дени і,
можливо, ви знаєте Тару Степаненко, він на
фут нижче  з донецького Шахтаря і
деякі з них навіть були представлені на наших
уроках звичайно ви знаєте спортсменів
Віталія та Володимира Кличка
найпопулярніших найвідоміших спортсменів у
всьому світі з України
та Олександра OC ви, можливо, також найбільше знаєте
Janna clutch cover  відомий
плавець з України lilypad kappa vive
gymnastic та Еліна Світоліна теніс
добре і останнє завдання або я хотів
би запропонувати вам подумати, що можливо ви
візьмете інтерв'ю у деяких спортсменів, з якими
ви хотіли б взяти інтерв'ю, а для мене я
хотів би взяти інтерв'ю у Майкла Джордана
найкращий гравець найкращий баскетболіст
Національної баскетбольної асоціації Чикаго Буллз
Я хотів би
запитати його, коли він почав грати в
баскетбол, наприклад, чи коли він
виграв свою першу перемогу,
чи багато тренувався та чи
дотримувався спеціальної дієти, коли він  грав у
баскетбол, тому зверніть увагу на це
останнє запитання, тому що це буде нашою
наступною темою,
що їдять спортсмени, щоб добре
займатися спортом і  до речі, є дуже
цікавий фільм останній танець на Netflix,
раджу подивитися, тому наступною темою
буде здорова їжа, тому їжте правильно і
будьте здорові, але це ще не кінець
нашого уроку, тому що у нас домашнє
завдання все завдання  це проект, який я хотів
би запропонувати вам зробити спортивну настільну гру
спортивну настільну гру це гра, в яку ми можемо
грати на столі, зараз я покажу вам свій
варіант і поясню правила добре, у нас
є дошка один два три чотири п'ять
основ і  ми граємо, як у дуже простій
грі з кубиками, і робимо ваш рух від
початку навколо дошки до кінця добре, якщо
ви потрапите на базу G, це означає, що
вам слід виконати деякі граматичні завдання,
наприклад, що ви використовуєте під час гри в йогу
go або do  якщо ви дасте правильну відповідь, у
вас є п'ять балів, добре, наприклад, якщо
ви поставите знак питання,
це синя картка, це вікторина, ви повинні
відповісти на питання, де була
моторна Олімпіада в Римі чи в Олімпії, якщо
ви поставите правильний  відповідь у вас
чотири бали  добре, ви помрете і підете далі,
якщо ви підете, якщо ви потрапите в
апельсиновий шматок, вам просто потрібно
перекласти слова, наприклад, гіркий
хо-молодий будін Халіско забити гол ok,
за помаранчевий ви отримаєте три очки, а
зелена основа рухатися дуже легко, тому що
ви  потрібно зробити якусь вправу, наприклад,
стрибнути п'ять разів або побігати навколо столу,
і у вас також є ця база фіолетового кольору,
це база-сюрприз, ви ніколи не знаєте,
що тут трапилося, наприклад,
ви можете пропустити свій хід, вам потрібно залишитися
або ви можете йти вперед  три кроки або перейдіть на
п'ять кроків назад, щоб ви могли створити
власну настільну гру про підтримку добре,
це завершення нашої спортивної теми, побачимося
на наступному, дякую і до побачення
[Музика]
вам